Oh
[Music]
hello Tyra here I'm here at BuzzFeed and
I'm doing throw back teeth yes this is
not a false promise life-sized two will
be on your screen whatever screen you
use this Christmas this Kwanzaa this
Hanukkah this holiday season 2018 and
life science is gonna be different so if
you were a little girl or a little boy
you were like oh my god I love if she's
so cute and you have kids now that are
that age you might need to use a little
parent discretion whether or not they
should be watching life-size - or not
Lindsey slides into those DMS mmm-hmm
I'd be seeing you girl mm-hmm I split
into hers first to be honest because I
was like yo I'm producing life-sized -
but you down and she was like oh I'm I'm
down to the down like she's so down and
so we're working on the script now and
I'm telling the writer like I don't want
her to just have a cameo I feel like you
know she was just as important to
life-sized one as I was and so I wonder
to have like a role like at least three
four seems like and I think she would
play herself grown-up like Casey in
life-size and growing up we'll see
I am on the search for a high-level
producer dj khaled that will remix or
redo the be a star song dj khaled and
I'm hoping that whoever this producer is
dj khaled would come and just make it
the club banger where you just want to
shoot cannot do that dance dance shoot
till you drop so that's what I'm looking
for I'd have to say cycle 1 because it
was my baby it was so new and it's so
funny I know first and last names of
girls from cycle 1 Elise Sewell Shannon
Stewart Robyn Manning you know it just
goes on and on so yeah cycle one and
back then we were only doing one a year
so it was season 1 I remember there was
this thing like kind of behind the
scenes that we were like it's the
heathens versus the Christians or
something like that I mean I'm not
saying that my girls that were not
believers were heathens but that was
kind of the behind-the-scenes shorthand
of like how to describe both sides and I
think a heathen one but she was so
amazing Adrienne was like on my list I
have a list of all of the girls at the
audition process and whether or not they
should get in or not and next to
Adrienne's name I said no and then she
ended up being an alternate and then she
ended up winning because she had some of
the fiercest pictures all cycle I've
wanted to for so long so over the years
I've created Dex
as you know it's like pages and pages of
like something and you're trying to
present something that somebody as to
why they should do something I convinced
them for years have been saying we need
to do a plus this was before it was
called curvy plus tees and a plus-sized
season plus Pisces and then they keep
saying no so it's kind of like my hands
are tied at least with America's Next
Top Model for now but who knows I mean
the world has changed and we're no
longer at the forefront of like the
curvy girl thing now we have Ashley
Graham and so many other girls and
Instagram girls are blowing it up that
our curvy girls so maybe our new network
might say yes I got to pull out that
deck again
I'm really proud of Lila and Winnie
Harlow
so Lila came on top model she was
runner-up and now she is running for it
she's been in G Vaughn she campaigns
she's on everyone's runway she is
killing it killing it killing it
she is truly the epitome of high fashion
and all over the world really doing so
well she's not a Victoria's Secret model
so you might not know her name but
everybody in high fashion does honey and
if you don't need to like get with it
Winnie Harlow is okay I'm so proud of
her because last year the Teen Choice
Awards announced the top 5 that people
could vote for for Top Model top Top
Model not America's Next Top Model but
like the best model of the Year Bella
Hadid and Gigi Hadid Karlie Kloss and
you know all the big girls of today and
Winnie Harlow a girl that I found on
Instagram and put her on America's Next
Top Model so she makes me proud every
single day yes I am vented smizing I
wouldn't say invented the action but I
invented the word
I was so tired of saying smell with your
eyes so I decided to shorten it so this
is not smizing it's just like dead eyes
and this is smizing
are you ready can you handle it
you need to peer into the lens as if
you're you know kind of can't see that
well you're a little upset and maybe
you're thinking about ice cream
something makes you happy
you're selling the magazine cover you're
selling the fact that you're so fierce
you're selling the fact that this wig is
matted but you don't want people to look
at the matted wig you want them to look
at your smile you're selling the fact
that your knees are so ashy but your
smile is so fierce they don't see the
dryness that is below your thighs it's
nice I loved loved loved Beyonce coming
on the Tyra show she would come all the
time when Beyonce came Beyonce came two
hours before the show started and damn
near stayed two hours after it was over
like looking at tape and making sure
everything was okay she was such a
perfectionist she needed all that time
and I gave it to her she didn't know I
was looking at her but I got to see her
rehearsing and telling her crew like do
this and do that and back in the day
people thought Beyonce was just like yes
ma'am you know I'm from Houston and I'm
just so nice and happy and she's a nice
girl but she's a businesswoman and I got
to see why she's so successful because
she knew lighting sound every single
thing and so she was fine and she always
did a little something a little extra
crazy on my show which was funny there's
this thing about like old shows coming
back and getting insane ratings like
Roseanne just came back she got 23
million people watching that show so of
course if the Tyra show comes back we're
gonna have like 35 million right so I'm
tempted
Roseanne me and you Bing Bing okay Blake
Lively is an alien I have never seen
someone be able to text somebody and
make faces like what and they go action
she puts her phone down and it's like
Dan what I can't believe it you do what
to me what you are whipped whatever okay
oh no you didn't actually
what alien genius
conventional Beauty boring I like a
little something a little off a little
eyebrow that's a little higher you know
hair that's a little uneven skin that
has different skin colors eyes that are
not just like oh my gosh they're a lips
that are like too big too small Chin's
that are you know a little too plain II
foreheads that are too big I think
things like that just make the world
more beautiful when it's a little askew
the amazing thing about Will Smith is
that when you're on set you hear him
before you see him he announces himself
what's up everybody like such positivity
so the fact that he was so happy and so
amazing and so just like just delectable
may like onset really great and you know
I learned that like this the show was a
family like already not just a
television family but like a crew a
family they've been together for so long
and hearing I'm the new one coming this
ed like so I felt really awkward and I
remember karyn Parsons asking me to go
to lunch do you miss she didn't talk
like that Hilary banks look like that
but she'd be like Tyra to lunch and I
was so nervous and so scared and I would
always say no because I felt like well
they're our family and they don't want
me but here she is asking me to lunch
all the time so I learned like mel's
into the situation Tyra don't be so
scared
[Music]
one of the most memorable not
necessarily be but one of the most
memorable was during the Academy Awards
I was hosting the red carpet for the
actual academy awards themselves it
wasn't like another channel or anything
it was for the Academy Awards and I went
to Vera Wang and I was like Farah that
trust is amazing but it was a private
because it was like a wedding dress and
she's like okay I'm gonna make it for
you in Navy and I was like maybe uh then
I was gonna look like a host like I have
on my dark dress and I'm interviewing
celebrities and I don't wanna look like
that I'm gonna look like I just so
happened that I could walk the red
carpet or I can interview so I need to
what color and I convinced her to make
it laughter so I was on a lot of
interesting lists that year some people
said that little bo-peep lost her sheep
up under my dress some said it was like
a Disney Princess gone wrong they were
clueless and they were lost to me I was
on the best-dressed list that year even
if it was there's so much that I have
planned for the model and series stay
tuned I'm in a couple of months maybe in
the next 12 months or so you're gonna
see Madeline take a swerve on a curve
like model and is gonna come to you in a
way that I'm most proud of being first
like being the first you know black
Victoria's Secret model on the cover to
have a contract for black angel the
first black woman to wear that fantasy
broad diamond thing or being the first
model female model on the cover of GQ
can we pause record scratch people say
oh yeah tire was the first black model
on GQ no first female model on the cover
of GQ
let's get her right I can remember it
like yesterday
I thought she was gonna win I felt like
she should have won and I'm still
rooting for her I think she's rooting
for herself and I think she's that girl
is special even when I did that whole
thing she was still trying to make
everybody in the room Phyllis she's
still trying to make sure everybody
cool good and I'm still rooting for we
all are but she's one for herself now
she's doing her thing
[Music]
or speaker you Liang Liang